Check out this awesome multitool.
Consider the possibilities.
If I have this baby with me, I could eat
a steak on the go wherever I want to.
On second thoughts,
it's going to be way more pleasant if
I just use this fantastic knife here.
Sure, it doesn't have all the bells and
whistles, but
it's really good at its main job,
being a knife.
And now we're talking IDE versus editor.
An IDE, short for
Integrated Development Environment.
Is an attempt to create a development
productivity Swiss army knife
that can do it all.
Editing, debugging, building,
compiling and even, optimizing.
But, IDEs come at the expense of
tools that do one thing really well.
That's not to say that IDEs never work.
Far from it.
For app ecosystems, such as iOS or
Android, the vendor offers official
support, and controls both
the programming language, and platform.
Which is why why so many of native
developers use Xcode, Android Studio, or
Visual Studio.
But on the web, we already have
to live with fragmentation.
Different browsers,
devices and standards.
We could try to pretend that CSS,
HTML and JavaScript come in a beautiful
tightly controlled bundle and
build an idea around it.
Or we could do what most web
developers decide to do.
Embrace the chaos and
use individual tools best for
each job while ensuring that
they function well together.